infinity
this was a big gig for clarence and
napoleon
showtime in a club in their hometown
hamburg the electro pop duo loves
performing live
it's like being born when you're on the
stage and then you die again when you
leave it like packing a whole life into
one evening in fast motion
will that pull me onto the stage or
scare me to death that's what it's about
you know
they describe their sound as electronic
dream pop between melancholy and disco
a drummer backed up that powerful voice
at this gig
this mix of melancholy songs with songs
you can really dance to is really
something special
that's
breaking the silence their first single
came out in spring as a taste of the
album of the same name
and then came the next song five seconds
their current single angels came out
this autumn and so did their debut album
clarence and napoleon's songs all sound
very different
but they've got one thing in common
all of our songs have something of a
goodbye in them and a starting over
it's a bit of a gray zone between the
two arriving and going away
it's all about change there's a certain
despair there but it's couched in a real
sense of calm and melancholy
anabawa and anastrauba have been a
musical item for five years now
their rehearsal room isn't anna's
parents garden
the duo find the peace and quiet they
need to write songs here
that last bit sounded really great
let's try it again we know what to do
the knight inspires them as well
the band processes these trips into a
parallel world in their music
the partying you associate with
nightlife has different sides to it
there's euphoria the rush but an
emptiness and sadness too
i think that plays a big role for us
now they're gearing up to perform at the
repavonn festival at a club in the heart
of hamburg's clubbing district
they're just getting ready backstage
warming up for this important gig
no gig it's like the next one
you don't know what it's going to be
like
not even a minute before you go on stage
it's always a surprise
clarence and napoleon have set
themselves two goals for the future
to write lots of new songs and perform
them all over the world